hello everyone thanks for joining us for
cnam second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development I'm Celia are now a senior
editor at CNN and I'm delighted to
introduce our next speaker who is worth
less kovitch program coordinator for hit
validation and chemistry for the
community for open antimicrobial drug
discovery at the University of
Queensland in brief written in Brisbane
Australia a Canadian mark did his
undergraduate work at the University of
Victoria in British Columbia and his PhD
at the University of Waterloo in Ontario
he has extensive medicinal chemistry
experience and over 15 years of
industrial drug development experience
most recently as chief operating officer
at new medica in Australia at new medica
he managed the drug discovery and
development program from milana court
and five receptor antagonists work that
led to a compound currently in Phase two
human trials for the treatment of acne
he's there at the University of
Queensland since 2010 mark will be
presenting a talk entitled synthetic
chemists to aid the community for open
antimicrobial drug discovery I'll be
back to moderate a Q&A session
immediately following the presentation
when welcome your questions at any time
just click the green Q&A button in the
left corner of your screen and if you
need any technical assistance during the
presentation please click on the support
button located top right of your screen
please note that sandy n does not
endorse any company products or services
that may be mentioned in this
presentation finally this talk will be
archived and available on demand at the
conference website for three months
after the live broadcast until December
16 2015 and now I'm delighted to hand
over to mark thank you very much Celia
and I'd like to thank the American
Chemical Society and chemical
engineering news for providing me the
opportunity to present a talk about our
community for open open antimicrobial
drug discovery so this talk is going to
be a little bit different from other
chemistry talks well fancy and that I'm
not going to be so much presenting
results of what we're done but inviting
synthetic chemists
around the world to help participate in
a program to try to come up with new
antibiotics now the reason this is
needed is because there is what's
commonly called the superbug crisis so
there's been a lot of popular press in
recent years over the rise of these
highly drug-resistant superbugs and a
lot of it has been quite sensationalist
on my favorite segment that top left
where is a mop of yet but these press
articles do reflect a reality that we
are facing as the who has called it a
world is heading back towards a
post-antibiotic era so similar to the
area before antibiotics were discovered
common factions and minor injuries can
come deadly in layton kill you so things
that we've been able to treat
successfully for decades with
antibiotics are going to once again be
able to kill you and there's a number of
reasons why this is occurring so the
rise of resistance has been happening
for many years so if you look at this
plot with the timeline on top window
antibiotics are first employed in the
timeline on the bottom when any product
resistance was first observed if you
highlight around here at the very
beginning with the first penicillin
resistance was detected within two to
three years similarly up in the future
more recently I drug discovery with
Williams it and daptomycin again only
with a few years of introduction of the
antibiotic resistance was observed and
so this has led to the superbug crisis
where potentially by 2015 their
predictions that over five million
people a year are going to be dying from
best attributable to end in microbial
resistance so this has arisen by what's
called a perfect storm so this article
is a little out of davis from nature in
2011 and it illustrates that you have
this rise in resistance from a number of
different strains of bacteria and this
can be similar
strains similar resistance has been seen
a large number of different strains as
well but it's covered with a short
define the number of antibiotics that
are being approved every year and this
is largely due to the fact that most
major pharmaceutical companies FX
indiscreet so back in 2010 we've gone
from about 18 companies in 1991 to four
major forms left 2010 in that situation
hasn't changed much recent years there
had been a dinner of hope in that work
brought back into the game and bought at
Cuba's 2015 but unfortunately few months
later they laid off all the discovery
employees and similarly astrazeneca
which used to have a strong a valid
discovery effort I spun out as
antibiotic food into a small company
called antacid and july of this year and
that took about 175 antibiotic
researchers down to 21 so we're putting
out a survey now trying to estimate how
many antibiotic researchers are left in
the world and we think potentially
within within industry we're potentially
less than about a thousand and Radek
researchers around the world trying to
discover new antibiotics and so this
means we need new approaches to
reinvigorate gant waterfront so the
length of time it takes to develop a new
antibiotic if you consider from
discovery until it's approved if you're
looking at 10 to 15 years if we don't
start discovering new antibiotics now in
10 to 15 years when antibiotic
resistance will become prevalent across
the world and you have these strains of
bacteria resistant every now an
antibiotic it's going to be too late to
develop new antibiotics in recent years
have been a number of reports from the
World Health Organization from the chief
medical officer of Britain and from the
President of the United States which
reiterated that they need to be doing
something else so there is a growing
public and political awareness that we
have to start doing something now in
order to address the problem of
antimicrobial resistance and a lot 50
lakh you products so what types of
things can we do so a number of possible
approaches that take so we approach
which has generally been used for the
last 30
four years is trying to rationally
improve existing antibiotics so most do
antibiotics that are being approved are
improvements of existing classes and
sometimes that's able to overcome exist
existence but often it's just a more
potent version of an existing antibiotic
and because it's an existing class to
which resistance orly exists the same
issues of resistance to these new
antibiotic resign provides you can try
to rediscover old antibiotics so many
antibiotics that were discovered what's
called golden age nine develop research
during the 1960s were not developed into
clinical use for donnelly because
there's so many other choices
antibiotics at that time so one
potential approach is to go back to the
literature 60s try finding some of these
antibiotics to identify back then and
see if they have any promise of
properties in order to develop it now
when a third approach is to discover
untested and chemical diversity
essentially there's a concerted effort
to basically go back to the future so
returning back to natural product
discovery will almost all our existing
antibiotics in your change but the the
newer code is trying to investigate new
sources of these natural products so
looking at extrema files with maria
natural products and there are number of
different approaches that people can try
to do so uncovering eat bacteria fungi
by culturing under range of conditions
where you're able to do a lot for these
organisms rather than traditional
inventory on a prime example that is a
fairly recent highly publicized
discovery a fix of acting using
institute ship for growing bacteria in
the soil image they've found another
approach is to force microorganisms to
producing metabolites by growing them
under different types of course
conditions and even to search from the
tablets a genetic level you know the
gene clusters of producing and have
lights you can go searching another
bacteria other organisms to see if
they're similar types of fossils so
we've decided to try taking different
approach there quite a few other people
that are looking natural products but
the approach that Co add committee for
inviting me over breakfast club greater
is trying to find new synthetic
diversity from the compounds that
chemistry so I'm going to talk about
give it a couple of examples of all
three approaches and the first two
examples are used to illustrate some of
the capabilities that would build up at
the University of Queensland which we
are now applying for 30 mission hit
which is cool so in terms of improving
existing ambulance we have a program in
this car than cactuses so if you go back
to this chart looking at the rise and
evolve resistance a couple of striking
exceptions and one of them is vancomycin
so vancomycin was discovering the 1950s
and went for plus 30 years for
resistance was discovered so it's on the
few antibiotics that spent a long time
without a large amount of resistance in
the third inning right so we thought
vancomycin can surely be a good starting
from for trying to develop and you
improve antibiotic vancomycin is a
glycopeptide antibiotic it acts by
binding to the pentapeptide portion of
lipid to which is a precursor of a feed
of like and synthesis and because it's
on the surface of non positive bacteria
vancomycin and selective lyrics
gram-positive bacteria as opposed to be
im- of heaven how the membrane prevents
compromising to gain 50 like that so by
binding to this reality ala component of
the peptide vancomycin prevents the
peptidoglycan cross-linking from
occurring interfering with the cell wall
synthesis disrupting the integrity of
the bacteria so the number of blanking
like a peptide antibiotics and use of
vancomycin is a prototypical run sort of
first tico planning is another natural
product that was isolated approved in
Europe on us it's got a slightly
different structure actually sugars and
make a fellow group and I find another
by cyclic ring just now they're free
semi-synthetic antibiotics that have
been approved in recent years of Taliban
came is based on vancomycin I was
accrued 2009 gallivanting was approved
made last year I'm at space when I
motika plan and type of structure I
finally rid of banking I was approved in
august of last year not began this base
by vancomycin structure
on both babbling in a rid of anything
its mythical improved policy compared to
vancomycin but also have a rigorous and
half life which takes two so they can
either be once-weekly much less frequent
dosing than banking nice so our approach
are coming up with new American bison
derivatives was to try to selectively
increase targeting and vancomycin to
that to your membranes in preference to
mammalian member so try to reduce them
well harga text but also increase the
potency towards the desired target so
we're doing this by taking vancomycin
attaching on a positively charged
associate development which can interact
with the overall negative charge a
gram-positive bacterial membrane and
also have this look at phila group
attached to thank and I so much
potential can insert in the main grain
and provide a hydrophobic interaction so
by doing this now you increase the local
concentration but remembering
interaction at the site of its action
where lipid to is embedded at a number
on the increased affinity for the target
because now you've got identify me mode
lose some affinity because education the
two and resistant species potentially
you're still retain binding next to find
the membrane men potentially by binding
to vancomycin Thank You mice environment
target and the membrane directly inhibit
other membrane-bound I synthetic enzymes
involved being advises a pathway that
people i can and also disrupt a
bacterial membrane so the construction
that we're looking at so you have like a
peptide thank nice and we start off with
we append a diamino linkage of the seat
you nor ain't of Franklin nicely into
that we attach a kidik basically charged
associative element that has three amino
group I mean internal and the cap off
with a hydrophobic conservative element
consists of arrow or alkyl groups so by
with this modular construction is easy
to put together a large amount of analog
so we did in Sao our campaign with over
300 combinations this led us to a leaf
series of compounds where we have what
we call a pathfinder compound I'm
captain yeah and then to
lead compounds and caps and a in
venkatesan be so if you look at a panel
of bacteria and comparisons with the
series of other comparator antibiotics
so vancomycin oxazoline the nails with
adapt amaizing bala banking people
planning and television you can see that
a kinked the standard mrs a strains or
mrs am present significant serum my
captain systems have incredibly
important activity compared to
vancomycin so generally 3254 greater
potency of vancomycin an activity as
good or better than any other product is
currently on the market if you look at
like a peptide insensitive strains which
have a slightly increased mi c for
vancomycin or open this side you see
vancomycin mi stays gone from wrong
after 4 to 24 28 or a napkin meissen
business constrained or daptomycin
values of Grantham 122 off to run for
you can see that we still retained
reports agencies constraints upon phones
also have activity against strep
pneumonia and multi drug-resistant
species and retain that activity in the
presence of 5% lines of fact and when
again this is one area where Captain
Aizen doesn't work because its uses
except into the presence of runs back
young mi c90 testing for these
venkatesan and against 120 run staph
aureus mssa and mrs a strains or MSC 90s
again as good or better than characters
so highlighted below i'm doubtful
banking's about the most potent compound
out there and or MSC 90 ranges far
exceed those without them we do have
further testing gangsta additional
faradic under tysons progress I'm and
again that looks very pharmacy terms of
policy so one thing is very important to
assess is how quickly frequency might
arise in the two ways of doing that so
the first one is looking at the innate
existence how often bacteria already
possess resistant to the antibiotics so
generally they figure you want to see is
something that's less than
10-10 and it's dependent on the
concentration which you test your
antibiotic and often the see figures
afforded it at eight times mi see so
even at four x mi see against both a
memo saying stuff and ammonia and
captains am a taxi show excellent lack
of resistance visiting already actually
the other way to look for resistance and
this is more reflective of what happens
in the clinic when we're treating
patients is doing distance induction
study so this is looking at the growth
in resistance when bacteria exposed to
sublethal concentrations of antibiotic
at increasing concentrations just below
the sub-lethal dose over a period of
trying to aid with multiple generations
bacterial growth so you can see with
optimizing you get an increase going
from mi see around from five to run the
MSC goes up to four will be very
reflective of the resistance to see the
clinic and we also see with vancomycin
the similar rising assistance from an
Englishman I see if one after about 3-4
where it's been captain's down below
store that was being very important
probably do have some increase in mi
seas they're still in philly compared to
the other antibiotics so in terms of
potential for resistance the van
captain's look very promising so in
terms of drug development we've taken
them through the traditional type of
adamant properties I'm their statement
plasma and microsomes aims in Egypt
emissions beauty density and patrol
michael chicken skin toxicity is clean
there are some 13 additional potential
issues so we threw a guinea pig
cardiovascular model and conference
commenting forum on that [ __ ] binding
their curve the hypo combining which
ends up giving us a fairly good as a
half life in vivo and its second edition
we see no problems in terms of the major
skip enzymes is now in addition so in
terms of mouse PK you see an excellent
atc a PK profile compared to thank nice
and red with a very extended profile
which should be suitable for of these
funds they do say if not less to getting
that
with one is to apply efficacy model it's
just going to make the nice kind of
comforting Friday injection site awesome
ride and a zero there's an ejection of
ten petha see a few of em is a door
prize the antibiotics administered two
hours later it's dose after four hours
we take a blood sample just to make sure
we have Andy Barbra come forward and
they also recognize one control group of
mice at two hours just to see what to
see if you I is at the time of
antibiotic administration and then after
24 hours of administration of the
antibiotic sacrifice a nice look at the
CFU is contained on so this is appearing
again on the right hand side and caps in
a big handsome be against encourage or
antibiotics all those cake the left hand
side is our grounds or baseline at the
initial time of ejection of the
antibiotics so we've got around chemical
for see if you 24 hours later that's
risen the ceiling treatment up to Camden
I see huge bag you can see that attend
makes batik vancomycin amazed that have
very little effect daptomycin as
statistically lesson from serial key
lesson 101 efficacy spent Jackson a
shows good efficacy but concoction be so
stunning epic receding kicks it back to
equivalent or below the initial
infection amount and you can do a
dose-response study with Frank apps be
and get a really nice girls response if
I logical model and we've got vancomycin
does that 200 Mickey guys are very
positive control and you can see that as
a 25 maybe post within better reduction
in see if you then go to vancomycin
tenfold higher and you can even see some
efficacy reduction compared to the 26
hours post-infection in red with dose as
low as 25 so if accountants are also
efficacious in multiple in vivo models
or tested them in mrs a lung infection
model strep pneumonia survivor moral
bacteremia sepsis marble just in the
blood i'm on our legal
msn bacterial peritonitis other variety
different models is showing excellent
efficacy so in summary which bank app
since we show 16 to 64 more potent
vancomycin rack Jesus dreams and KF
taking offensive lines of acting they
show excellent efficacy in vivo models
there PK as a half-life paddler would
wednesday to inclusive or less than that
we've done toxicity studies so we
seven-day repeat dose aunt Cecily
testing or mice identity 10 times of
therapeutic dose and my effects include
we see no prolongation of a cutie Seema
guinea pig horrible in terms of mode of
action I'm advanced the mode of action
studies that show they do have multiple
modes of action beyond just kitty
vodacom synthesis inhibition and there's
very little susceptibility to both we
made indecent systems in terms of
commercialization potential these
compounds are protected by patents and
they're constantly synthesis is
comparable to other cameras AAS the
problem is now we're in what's called
the valley of death about compounds into
the creative promising in terms of
commercial potential there's very little
interest from the pharmaceutical
interests industry to take these
compounds or to raise funding from other
sources to get them from the lead
compound stage into that's partly
because just in terms of the antibiotic
crisis there's a lot of awareness of
ground making organizations but and a
belief that we have plenty of
antibiotics in the pipeline and current
treatments that are effective against
gram-positive bacteria but if you look
at the figure stones are 2013 uscgc
before done went well crisis if you
compare the number of infections on
ground positive negative have more than
a million in John positive just two
organisms mrs am Joseph hernia
encouraged or less than 50,000 grand
length even more striking the number of
deaths per year in the US alone is close
to 20,000 from ground positive and three
thousand gram negative so despite the
perceived need for gram negative
organisms currently he still don't have
effective I'm positive there on the esta
de marsay economic burdens grating
building
you're so I'm going to shift topics now
and talk about the second possible
approach closely observing oral
antibiotics and fast we're looking at
classes and bugs or rocket engines so in
terms of lipid peptide antibiotics
polymyxin which consists of colistin
chilling to be are currently used in the
clinic particularly as a last cell
therapy so these two antibiotics and
discovering the 1940s 50s they're
largely in Bandung to you to Neffe
toxicity issues and colistin is
generally ghost by masking these five
basic I mean very passive groups as a
poly my thanks Ron elated product or as
Polly mixing this ghost as the compound
the problem is that even though they're
being used for last resort era p there
are increasing number of strange that
rapidly developers as politics as well
so now you have strange bacteria
resistant to essentially every moment
and erotica are and people who get these
infections die and it's it's not often
the future this is happening now so that
the danger is these highly resistant and
you are species get transferred into
widespread use you're going to have a
real crisis very quickly not be able t
so the octo pectins our family of very
similar-looking little peptides that
were reported in the 1970s 80s have
generally been ignored the thing that
attracted our attention is that they
became activity against problems of
those strains and that's interesting
because they have a very similar
structures essentially the cyclic court
a ticket court is almost identical when
the factory by releasing at this
position instead of a 3 in pollination
carlston and then this linear peptide
tail is truncated so they've only got d
dad instead of an LVAD we moved to the
other amino acids including amount of
dad recipes and you have a slightly
different fatty acid tail that's
hydroxylated so we've gone ahead and
prepare some architekten c4 and talented
Gradstein cage these tubular goods on
some resistance conduction studies you
can see very clearly that for polymyxin
and holliston
quickly develop resistant to a very high
levels they start off up and I might see
if lesson done I could melt and within
20 days you're seeing resistance of grid
in 128 micrographs field again just
reflects what's going on in the world
where you get me very highly for some
strains of anything publicly in contrast
without repentance and for you start off
with less potency so the initial
activities around four micrograms per
mil but the rise and resistance levels
out and doesn't go anywhere near as high
as that climaxes so you're up to around
thirty two microphones so if you look at
the relative for change in mi see
probably makes Indian Carlos didn't have
Murali a thousand fold increase in mi
see so increase in resistance whereas
the auto captions we're down at about of
pride for groups of increased assistance
so this is really interesting in and
gives great potential for these to be
developed as new antibiotics so the
other interesting thing if you look at
the cross resistance of the induced
strains so the strains that have beamed
induced you're resistant to polymyxin so
the day 0 mi Satan's polymyxin b around
from one to five as in Carlos to hide a
20 degree and 120 whereas it retained
very soon we're actually making soft
edges before what's around eight goes
around doofus eight eight to 16
similarly the optin reduce resistance or
doctor kept in MSE is gone from eight up
to 32 became sensitivity to our lives so
despite their you know really similar
structures these two added classes of
antibiotics are acting by different
mechanisms of action or at least the
resistance reduction of different
mechanisms of action that pertains cross
sensitivity between the two other vials
we've done some preliminary mode of
action studies at your preparation for
paper we do show that I've been kept in
like the politics and binds to the lipid
confirming the day but to a lesser
extent it also primitive eights the
outer membrane that again to lesser
extent potentially reflects its reduced
potency compared to Williamson Carlston
assumably it permeates the cytoplasmic
membrane as well as day
of interest as well as that it shows
reduce my [ __ ] sisseton studies and so
particularly looking at kidding the
kidneys of my saline-treated with a
ceiling control of top Carsten on the
bottom left architekten see on Farland
right we see significant signs of damage
consistent with a metal toxicity
observed with colistin with occupancy
form you see negligible damage compared
to similar cases aliens again I'll it's
very promising as potential antibiotic
for developing so we're perceiving now
through a traditional SAR campaign can
improve the potency maintained will
reduce taxes it was compounds so that
the last part is talks going to focus on
our approach for trying to uncover novel
chemical diversity and this is our co a
door Committee for open mat in metroburg
discovery where we're trying to take a
community approach codes of discovery
and involve the rest of the world
particularly synthetic chemists and
helping discovered new antibiotics so
what is Collette it requires a global
initiative or they're trying to see any
chemical diversity the subway about the
crisis we're trying to seek out this
diversity from our passions that
chemists around the world anywhere and
we're trying to access these compounds
by providing free screening to the
chemist so that no cost to them against
pathogenic microbes and do testing
against five bacteria and come back an
important thing is that the chemists
retain all related so we're offering the
pre-screening providing the
pre-screening always also that chemistry
domestic compound and they retain normal
lives all the rights to the compound and
do whatever Lee Roth so the reason we
came up with this approach is that if
you look at antibiotics if you look at
the chemical structure they're not drugs
so they don't have a drug life rules so
pharmaceutical libraries the pharma
companies are all screened eligible time
successfully to do antibiotics are now
essentially designed around falling drug
by cruise so rule of five the penske
will reply capable bronze etc etc but if
you look at most marketing antibiotics a
break most conventional
so if you're running a traditional
medicinal chemistry campaign and
screaming a library that's been
proceeding to pay drugs like rules you
don't have any of these compounds in
there for the more they often are
reacted so highlighted all these
reactive functional groups present in
marketing antibiotics which if you're a
tradition medicinal chemist go to cut me
a new look at a hit and it's not one of
these structures in it he reviewed
you're going to say we're not going to
be developing that comp up anymore even
if you had it in your library to screen
to begin with because more unlikely
those compounds again it would have been
screened out of your your company's
forms of screening your library set so
if you look at chemical space this is a
summary of approved drugs so in grave
smaller circles or oral approved drugs
the red circles or prove a negative
antibiotics and circulatory positively
so if you look at the chemical space
referred property space just looking at
two physical chem from parameters and
likely awake and won't be it
gram-negative and garlic's in particular
occupy significant different chemical
space compared to where we find the
typical corporate archive which is
focused predominantly around trying to
make early available this is accentuated
if you can care for reverses academic
lexicon so if you look at physical
chemical properties again molecular
weight be the commercially sourced
diverse set of compounds or biotech
companies screaming robbery begin this
very narrow area of chemical space and
compare that if you look at Kemble and
publish academic antibiotics hormones
published compounds that have antibiotic
activity report campbell you have this
huge amount of diversity that's not
covered by the core project so
essentially if you're screaming for
libraries you're missing out ninety
percent of the compounds so how do you
find these other compounds so where do
you look for vision dr evolving so if
you look at chemical abstracts services
or rating alien organic compounds that
are registered and that's just looking
at compound
weightless hundred twenty-nine really of
these potentially have antibacterial
properties if you look at some physical
chemical properties that tend to
associate with particular brand
manufacturer activity 15 million of
these are academics or non-commercial so
the big question is how many of those 50
million are potential of products and
where do you find them well most of
those compounds have been made by
chemists developed because they're
developing these synthetic routes trying
to do SAR campaigns to some other
innocent chemistry project I've tested
them and now they're sitting in boxes on
the shelves in the back of bridges or
every grad student leave behind a box of
compound sitting in the back of the
fridge that 10 years down the road
sudden discoveries and ends up throwing
out because they don't know what to do
so these compounds have not been tested
so the 1.3 million 1.3 million compounds
reported in CA general a 14-percent are
reported with testing data it's bacteria
so how do we enable anyone discovery and
how do we access is capable versus
importantly how do we empower somebody
canvases on the world to test their
compounds and get data freshman
refractivity so in the past before in
the Golden Age particularly active our
discovery we collaborated on a very we
did research on the collaborative base
so we didn't have NT aids descent
compounds in one person's about this if
you look at the history of how i neva
discovered you know one person isolated
it send it off to some other person who
decent for the work on and I said what
the company we felt it as 90 erotic so
the word NPA's the word CDA is
preventing you from sending shipping
contrast each other everything is very
flattered a quad wants to return to that
collaborative air want your chemical
compounds of unions chemistry test
ranking on coral activity and the
important thing is you know this testing
we doing for you is free to use all you
have to ship us compounds and if you
can't afford the shipping believe in pay
for shipping design controls and the
reason we can do that is we have
significant funding the relevant trust
and support from universe Queensland
to enable us to provide this free
screening so the pathogens that we're
testing against as i mentioned we're
doing it inspired bacteria so these
pictures of courtesy atwood cbc 2013
report and i'm sure the show and I've
been antibiotic resistance presentations
all around the world now discipline very
nice statistics and very nice abilities
so Tessa engages in the vector signal
motivator journalist F and E coli and
klebsiella pneumoniae or gram negative
organisms for testing against time are
SAE those deaths pockets or this immense
existent and then to fungal species
candida albicans harvested foreman or
Alize have serious cases of growing and
public resistance and also cause a
number of deaths around the world so the
workflow super rad as we start off with
a primary screen when we receive
compounds so we test a single
concentration against five back the five
bacterial and fungal ever mention and he
hits from that we then go into a kick
confirmation so we do a concentration
range or a minimum mandatory
concentration test and then we count the
screen for cytotoxicity it gains
mammalian cells and that's very
important because a lot of compounds it
just getting toxic for bacterial fungal
and mammalian cells so if you have
something which is hitting mammalian
cells of the similar concentration as
it's hitting the bacterial cells is not
much opportunity for trying to improve
its selectivity and development are
there as part of that we also look at
membrane activity of the compounds
because that's often an indicator that
it just be generally toxic website of
prostitution sales as well we also make
sure that the compounds are pure and
what they say to make so we don't ask
the structures and compounds are
submitted we do ask them molecular
weights that we confirm that what has
been submitted has the correct
identification complement passes hit
confirmation and we're going to get
validation where we test into a larger
panel of bacteria we've got over 300
different isolates including atcc
reference strains and I'd like to point
out that the strange reason for primary
screen are all these reference strains
so other people around the world
okay testing after joining we tested the
presence of Syrians back to because
that's important to make sure the
antibiotics are being activated and the
Assessor preliminary assessment of the
drug blood property so dis plasma Mike's
instability protein bonding and their
ability to cause analysis blood cells
with the ax bad thing then we also do a
recent assist to confirm that content is
rock is meant to be and either go ad
will or if the original submitter has
other androids we will do analog testing
just to make sure it's not the singleton
hit and there's some opportunity to do
to lead produce over development so that
point it was also returned back to
forever i sentence compounds and it's up
to the person who has submitted the
compound what they want to do so they
can publish the data they can go on file
a patent on it or they can develop it on
your own we're more than happy to
provide guidance to people with english
know what to do next in terms of develop
the compound just idiotic because as you
see we have experience in taking
conference for the demographics of the
pipeline but this reiterated up to the
person's main compound they have full
control over what happens with the data
the only thing that the world can trust
wants us to do is develop a public
database clanking the close of the data
and so within 18 months of the originals
of us sending you back data based on
their compound your request that you
supply a structure of your compound
entering the public database and other
researchers around the world were able
to look at the structures positive and
negative activity and try to develop a
potential to have algorithms to predict
whether a vacuum i would also like to
reiterate though if you have a compound
that you haven't get a time to publish a
patent or develop and you don't want to
disclose the structure yet it's just you
can request an extension from us from
leaving months before you have to supply
us questions but this in terms of
workflow we're working in conjunction
compounds australia which has a large
compound collection and probably have
setup compound wicked Haman saloons and
storage facilities so we're using them
to help
managed compounds which incidentally to
us we are doing our screaming in a high
throughput manner so we're doing our
initial screening them in the 40 of em I
see lasses 384-well on that I've got a
robotics lab set up for testing and I
mentioned we do 384-well screening and
we can argue effectively read by using
sizer in the fluorescence so in terms of
pilot validation which is a normal
Hyperion validation so here's just group
controls that unit staff or is it amonos
you can see that we do did variations
became of that carries and how easily
reproducible oh and I'm in terms of
retail optimization if you're reading
only 600 for density then you can easily
pick out your kids that come up when you
convert it over percentage position in
terms of pilot validations are in order
to get funding from the Wellcome Trust
initially you need to demonstrate to
them that we have the capability of
screening large number of compounds and
identify needs for that so the pilot
validation we tested for over 160,000
compounds a large number of these are
from drug like to first resource
collections but we also access over
20,000 compounds that have academic life
properties from total existing
collections of academic like compounds
so if you look at the hit rate that we
receive the commercial get rates
positive and negative very similar to
what's important industries very low
rates that from silly percent positive
and about 10 12 Laura Levin may be
different that's consistent also with
the fact that there are negative
condition they have much more of a
positive but if you look at the academic
if rates the ground positives we're
about 10 for higher ground negative
we're almost 100 photography so we
believe that there's evidence that the
academic collected potentially going to
be able to give us a much higher hit
rate of biologically active compounds
that I'd 90 micro directivity in terms
of current screening so the pilot
program are full screening program but
funding has been running since every of
this year's member services once then so
far we receive
about 6,000 compounds from 15 different
countries and over 35 collaborators
allow those are coming in as small
collections of kendall harmful compounds
within those 6,000 compounds we have had
some large collections of people who
actually already have the compounds take
it out in 96-well plates in solution
with screen 5,000 those compounds very
importantly we have 120,000 caramel
identified promised to us that will be
submitted at some point right there for
another reasons they're delayed in in
terms of people waiting to send us they
haven't had time to weigh the mound for
the waiting to be will be so hopefully
within the next four months we'll have
100,000 compounds screening for them
couette have identified potentially more
than million others here are are several
existing national compound collections
around the world will try to tap into
but obviously it takes a while for those
larger collections to get laid in terms
of hit confirmation so from these exact
6,000 compounds were tested we've got
two hundred hits so far that are FEMA
sets for bacterial fungal and cytotoxic
activity with 80 confirmed hits against
bacteria and sick students combat I can
hit validation so from the compounds of
receives its beginning of the program
none of those at the end of genetic
validation but from the pilot screening
program where 47 confirmed hits that
have entered test important validation
where we're starting to do some
resynthesis preparation of an rods and
testing against expanded on my seat so
in terms of trying to happen to chemist
it on the world what do we need from you
so all we need is a milligram of pure
compound so we don't want to be
screening extrusion vector product
fractions we want pure compounds the
compounds need to be solid when we're
doing this oh and they need to be stable
in solution so they can't be so reactive
that they fall apart and decompose and
report we are able to take if you
already have your compounds as ten
minimal work being with those dots we
can take 50 nitric Norwood fifty
microliters of a que no more pretending
familial DMSO stock rather than late one
milligram
so what do you get back so you get
screaming results being supplied that
turn into fun right if any of those are
hits then you get the further hip
confirmation we get validation lashes
are done so that whole screening process
done free and all the results to that to
you again I reiterate you retain all the
rights to your compounds and do whatever
you want terms publishing patio develop
our coed requests after acknowledges in
the acknowledgement section take you
like this coverage we have a website at
www add Ford and armless website we have
a button for sending compounds that
pulls are a simple firm Rhine initial
compound screening submission form or
basically asked for some preliminary
information how many compounds and we're
very soon after that in touch with you
to provide you with further details so
run this submission form you do have a
disco simple software license of
conditions that you agreed to so from
our perspective this is the only
requirement that we have employee status
compact now if your institution there
pas reason to have an MPA or further
legal rooms in place we do have a simple
no signature or very simple MTA and you
consent to your institutions so why is
quite different so currently there's no
open access public private partnership
dedicated so link antibiotics so their
issues for malaria dishes TV nothing for
antibiotic development it's a unique
effort trying to discover chemical
diversity within academic compound
collections that chemistry synthesized
over the years you're very few labs in
the world have already bought discovery
capabilities under run routes this is
partly what we found in our some of the
initial antibody discovery programs is
that weird one of the rare labs that
have both microscopy expertise
antibiotic screaming capabilities so in
terms of microbiology we've got hundreds
of gram-positive strains have an annual
changes and testing we're familiar with
doing resistance frequency and
resistance abduction assays we have a
capability within
Queens and sequencing we can do now
efficacy models either at the University
please land world with external partners
that we have contracts place with
assumably we can do mode of action
studies for kind of determine the mode
of action products in terms of admin
again internally we can do ties in
microsomes or aleppo finding and in
combination to see our partners your
contacts facebook we can do safe in
addition again most importantly we
scream for you so you don't have
anything to do but the property the
submitter retains all the way students
so in terms of trying to outreach
programs our biggest effort right now is
time to get chemist asan this compound
so we've made a very concerted effort to
go run to conferences and try getting
science publications place so we've had
editorials chemical engineering news and
particle macys diseases we've been
featuring my number of loose particles
and very recently we had a particle of
matrix retrospective so this to finish
off this is our team the center melilla
pictures the principal investigator
Cooper set up the group which is led to
collecting established the head of
logistics kinematics canvas to age i'm
headed microchip screening ish Elliot on
a charge of hit validation chemistry and
until to sell and with Neil turn charger
and each program I'm doing our systems
analyst or computational backup and and
helping out with administrations and the
cow and then it was got a biology team
of microbiologists India Angela be
running all the action sports this
diamond junction of oxygens fraser and
adjacent instituted uqs helping us out
with the ending on plastics so that's
all i have to say i'd strongly encourage
you if you have interest to send this
conference testing and check out our
website and be more than happy to answer
any questions you have to ask thank you
okay so we actually already have some
questions a couple of them have to do
with the free aspect of this is there
any limit on the size of the library for
free screening and is the free screening
only for the first time or perpetual
cleaning is perpetual as long as we
spilt or I cut in there the free
screening is perpetual as long as we
still have funding or compressed so we
have pilot funding to last for 18 months
which takes us until August next year
and assuming we meet for our milestone
goals which basically are based on
participation and uptake and when we're
most of the way there for all of our
metrics already we're very confident
we'll be able to obtain further funding
to continue the initiative in terms of
the size of the library the more the
better so we've identified some
collection of 20,000 compounds that we
will be screening and hopefully if
people have many compounds they're
already in paper format and we can be in
touch with you and organize the
preferred Clayton 4matic if you're able
to take them out to help our hydrogen
screening okay what is the time period
from the submission of samples until the
screening results so we're still in the
process of setting up our full
automation I'm currently right now in
terms of the primary screening the
results are generally returned within
4-6 weeks hopefully wants our
automations fully up and running we fit
into the ability to generate reports
automatically by the knife into right
now by hand the turnaround time should
be within a month for the primary screen
obviously if you have if we get a hit a
few follow-up confirmation those results
take longer to get back but we do
generate interim report so if you have
hit compounds which I get any the
initial report just let me know that you
have some compounds and then be the hit
confirmation report
hopefully we will have back within two
to three months okay the essay you are
using to test the small molecules for
them their potential antibiotic products
is based on OD 600 nanometer readout how
do you cope with small molecules
interfering with the lead out those that
absorb at 600 nanometers are you using
any counter SI or secondary essays with
orthogonal rebounds so with the number
of compounds that we're putting through
the screening campaign we're not able to
pre-screen to see if there are
interference but if they do there are
kids that come out that would be one the
first thing we can say as I mentioned we
have two possible assay measurements so
either doing the couple density read to
look at the amount of bacterial growth
or doing a ruse as or an assay which
gives a color upon lecture event
okay what are some of the most promising
screening results you've had so far I'm
so it's still fairly early stages one of
the more interesting results found some
compounds which have selective activity
just against us in the bacteria mommy so
that's one of the interesting things
that life by screen against multiple
bacterial strains the normally you see
discrimination gram-positive
gram-negative but being able to see some
selective activity towards one bacterial
strain amongst gram-negative is quite
interest because potentially in the
future particularly if the diagnostics
of infections become much improved so
you're able to rabbit it and if I what
type of bacteria is causing convection
having a discriminatory and illogical to
select only the bacteria causing
infection could be very powerful because
you wouldn't harm the normal flora and
fauna in addition to the pathogen I've
tried to kill in terms of potent
compounds we haven't yet found things
that are important promising but you
know we're very early stages with 6,000
compounds and you know an estimated
screening get paid or more percent up
and have to default as expected yet will
your team help facilitate business
development efforts for any promising
compounds discovered in the program yeah
so the output of of go ad is at a very
early stage so in terms of attracting
business interest from pharmaceutical
company in particular the type of
preliminary data that yep go ad has be
far too early for track any significant
interest from commercial companies
however the more than prepared to
provide guidance and advice as to what
you can do to develop these compounds
and there are a number of initiatives
which I've been developed particularly
with the money presidential initiative
States or alternatively the innovative
medicines initiative Europe has a
program called enable will
page essentially the output but kool ad
will be providing so validated it
compounds but activity less than 30 25
mil and that's the ideal input for this
enable initiative where the trying to
take those APIs or diem of academic
commercial companies which to hit to
lead to clinical discovery development
with those compounds so we're looking
and trying to develop a collaboration of
enable because you know it's a perfect
marriage in terms of where we end and
they stood so we're certainly willing to
provide a lot of guidance to people as
to what they might be able to do with
those compounds can you elaborate upon
why the chemical space distribution of
academic library versus corporate
compound libraries are so radically
different sure that's based on the whole
premise that drug pharmaceutical
companies are very focused on trying to
develop orally available problems or
oily available compounds and the target
classes that drug discovery companies
are generally aiming for us at GPC are
receptor ligands kinase is cody's
committees are fairly narrow select
properties and so particularly when
you're using these rules to constrain
for availability guidelines it really
restricts the chemical space so you're
not going to develop anything that's out
of molecular weight 500 button
antibiotics like vancomycin and depth
nice and revived the easier for more
than a thousand so you've need to
eliminate the ones potential antibiotics
so the academic chemical space is so
much faster because they're not using
these rules so academics that are doing
natural products emphasis that are
developing pathways for methodology
development aren't aren't worried about
rules at all because we're just focused
on making of it they care about those so
the only academics that might be focused
on rules or medicinal chemistry
academics who are trying to do
selectively targets and follow the
industry standard a focus in the North
correlated or compounds but no medicinal
chemists form of
small fraction of synthetic organic
chemistry wants that a chemist setter as
I mentioned your methodology development
trying to come up with your reactions is
coming up for any reaction will make
urity different animals that's a perfect
set for us to test reticle activity
because potential is already some I say
I'll build okay I think we have time for
one more question so I this will be the
last one will you be screaming only
small molecules and synthetics or are
you open to screen peptides as well if
so what has been a success rate with
peptide antibiotics screams so we're
more than happy to screen peptides as
well in terms of peptide antibiotic so
they're quite a few cyclic peptide
enigmatic so daft nice nepali mix-ins
for our cyclic peptides and they've been
very successful the advantage of
antibiotics protective gram-negative is
that intravenous use is perfectly
acceptable and often desirable and so
for those reasons and peptides are
sufficient if they're particularly
cyclic peptides are stable enough to
last they don't have to worry about or
availability issues generally one of the
restrictions on using peptides drugs
there's been a lot of effort in
developing linear antimicrobial peptides
and to date those haven't had a lot
success ones that are generally membrane
lytic and there's probably a lot more
research going on if those now in terms
of their immunomodulatory property
throughout is restricted or anything I
would just like just being a couple of
questions that I very quickly would
address in terms of the amount of
compound boom sent to us so we don't
need exactly milligram we need
approximately a milligram and you can
send it to us ideally as a solid but if
you already have it dissolved up the
GameA so you can send us a game as
though stock solution is only to know
that the concentration of it is the only
problem with shipping gameís out
solutions generally want a chip on dry
ice they don't be
okay that's all the time we have many
thanks mark for your fascinating
presentation and thanks to all of you
for tuning in there will be more great
talks beginning at the top of the hour
and throughout the day you can find the
full program on the agenda page located
at the upper right-hand side of your
screen in the meantime please stop by
the virtual exhibit hall and a lounge to
check out our sponsors and exhibitors or
network with other attendees join the
conversation on twitter with hashtag cen
715